je donnais la définition d'une saloperie
s'est laissé partir un agent sur le
terrain alors qu'il n'est pas
opérationnel ça c'est sale et les morts
probables non n'a pas de confirmation
je savais qu'ils agacent d'avoir à c'est
lui moi aussi
cette nouvelle peut déstabiliser tous
les agents sur le terrain easterly plus
machine qu'est ce qu'on cherche
vous aurez fait ça
les ennemis de mes ennemis sont mes amis
je souhaiterais que vous encaissez sont
impossibles patron c'est l'envoi des le
cas
je suis pas fait pour ça il a été formé
pour ça je leur mettre un terme à des
missions
voici la liste des personnes à
fréquenter
pour notre existence d'une torpeur
d'euros a été balancé exception on n'est
pas de famine arrivent on assez réaliste
d'origine observe
il découle est choquée en interne
[Musique]
pour le grand retour du plus secret des
services secrets la paranoïa atteint des
sommets on ne peut pas travailler avec
des gens sur nalement donc une option
le vrai danger être soi-même créations
originales
le bureau des légendes saison 5 inédite
lundi soir sur canal +